I was on Denbies Hillside a
couple of years ago and I got
this rather lovely shot
of the Adonis Blue.
It's quite rare in most
places, but on Denbies
Hillside, near Dorking, it's
prolific in the spring time.
Not only is it a very beautiful
butterfly, but also
it has a particular scientific
interest for optics because
the blue color it has
isn't generated by
chemicals, by dyes.
It's caused by the structure
of the wings.
There's a microstructure in
the wings which diffracts
light and it just diffracts the
blue light, which is what
produces that very
intense blue.
And that hinges on some ideas
I've been developing in my
scientific life, which is to
control light with a new class
of materials, called
metamaterials.
And their function is due
to their structure.
But the butterfly
got there first.
I'm John Pendry and I'm a
professor of physics at
Imperial College London.
I work on the theory of
how to control light.